In fact this equation doesn't just describe the work required to move bucket of mass m of a height 8 h.
This is the potential energy that a bucket has once it's at the site.
For potential energy we use the letter u and since there's many type of potential energy,
I'm going to use this subscript g to remind us we're dealing with gravitational potential energy.
Now one thing I should point out is that this height in this equation seems to be really special.
How did the bucket know it's potential energy should be
related to its height above this water level?
Why it could have been that high or why can the height have been negative?
As when the bucket is below somewhere at this point.
In fact all of this choices for our reference zero point potential of energy
whether it's here or down here or even up here are totally valid.
Where we choose our zero point is completely arbitrary, but once we choose our zero point
we have to consistent while we're solving a problem and you'll see what I mean by all this
when we keep solving more problems and now of course the question is, "Why is this idea useful?"
"Why do I care about potential energy?"
Well, why don't we solve the problem that you could not have solved 10 minutes ago.